it's a weird moment when you do this
because
like we let's just say you're going to
come up with a prediction of the future
and it's not so bright
there's a weird moment of satisfaction
you have when you're like aha i was
right and then you're like
oh no i was right no it's like
here come the terminators i knew it i
knew it great
wonderful
this is jonathan pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
so hello everybody i am sitting here
with neil degrade
neil degrade is a musician he is uh
the uh the headliner for a band called
dirt poor robbins
but he's also done so much in music
world written scores for movies for
different shows he's been in several
bands and he's also become
uh quite a participant in the symbolic
world
he is in contact with a lot of people
that are kind of swirling around the
videos
i've been in discussion with him for
several uh
for like years now or like over a year
over a year now and we're also looking
at doing some projects together so i'm
really excited
to have him on the the show mostly to
talk about
how it is that artists can predict the
future
oh this is where i talk i could okay if
i was gonna predict in the future i
could have predicted that
oh that's a good setup i like that uh
this is a great topic
um i guess i i gotta give you a little
background yeah so
i i was born into a family of
entertainers and musicians so both sides
of my family
pretty much across the board all musical
all entertainers
most in many professional at one point
uh
really funny thing i like to tell people
is that my i found my parents my parents
marriage certificate and on the marriage
certificate back then you
like in the 60s you had to put your
parents occupation so my
dad's father he was a radio announcer
entertainer and my
mom's father was a radio announcer
entertainer so there was like a part of
like my i think i was genetically bred
to be on the radio and just
missed like stepped out of the stable
and missed my calling
so uh but it was a family of
entertainers and
so there was no question that i was i
was going to learn music
it was going to be forced on me whether
i liked it or not and it turned out that
i really liked it
so um my dad used to bring home
records from the radio station and he
the first one i ever get
i think really explains what we're doing
the best because he brought home two
records for me and my brother to pick
from one was kiss
and the other one was queen it was news
of the world and my brother
picked kiss and you know if you listen
to kiss and what they've stated their
goal was gene simmons says like we
weren't trying to be the beatles like
every other band we wanted to be
coca-cola
and that's like totally my brother he's
like brilliant with marketing
and he's had an incredible career with
that and he's kind of went off that way
and i
picked queen uh which you know queen i
think was trying to be an opera
or a movie and so that would like that
just blew my tiny mind and the artwork
on that record was like this
isaac asimov take where there was this
you know giant robot i guess we could
pull this up at the toi i'm saying this
um
but you know had was killing like the
members of the band and it like really
tripped my little five-year-old mind out
five years old yeah man oh dude yeah
that really just
that that was it for me that ruined me
as far as being able to do anything
normal with music
i was it's all going to be theatrical
and cinematic from that point on
yeah and that's the an interesting
aspect of your work which you know your
band your poor robin's
there really is a storytelling aspect to
the band there's like
almost like you said an operatic there's
some nostalgia there's something
melodramatic about the way that things
are presented
um and so i can really i didn't i
wouldn't have
thought right away queen but when you
say it i'm like yeah that's that makes a
lot of sense that well there are
definitely other influences in there so
kate
is really the band is myself and my wife
and we've used a lot of other incredible
musicians and people play with us over
the years but
kate and i met uh when i was in my early
20s
and she is really the other half of the
band she she kind of taught me
i would say how to write lyrics uh she
was already she already had a music
career going we met
she was younger than me but i was this
really poor guy living in providence
rhode
island and there was a musical that was
auditioning in town it was supposed to
be going to broadway
and some people showed me some examples
of it i thought it was incredible but i
had like zero
interest in being in a musical so i did
not want to audition but i was hitching
a ride with my friends and they said
they would drop me off where i wanted to
go
if i would just audition with them which
was strange
so the audition was really weird because
generally it's like you know you see
these in movies where there's this panel
yeah many people watching and it that
was there but it was also in an
old church in new england so everybody
waiting to audition
was still in the was in the audience so
you're auditioning in front of all these
other people which i didn't care about
because i
didn't plan on doing a musical there was
one part left and they were auditioning
the mail lead and they were like going
nationwide trying to find this guy
well i got up to audition and i decided
my
job was going to be to make my friends
laugh and it somehow translated as like
confidence and composure
and stage presence and i had very little
experience in musicals and
so the next day i get a call and they're
like hey listen congratulations you got
the part
and i was like oh that's so nice i don't
want the part though like you know i'm
sure you've got
there were a lot of people there that
were great i'm sure you've got them
there and then
and so i turned it down and then the
writer of the musical called me back and
uh his name was enrico garzali he was
really interesting guy
um but he started he started explaining
to me a very strange angle as why i
should do this he's like
i cast you because you go perfectly
with the girl we cast for the lead he
said you guys
are going to want to you're going to
want to marry this girl 100 and
i think there's going to be incredible
chemistry and then like and she was from
los angeles she auditioned out on the
west coast
and uh i was like well maybe i could
show up to a couple rehearsals so
i i said yes and i showed up and
the first meeting i had with kate where
we had to sing is
she just you know got in front of me and
her part in this duet went first and she
started to sing and i never heard
anything like this like coming out of
someone's mouth
three feet you know it's really
uncomfortable to have someone staring
you in the eyes with like complete
confidence in just singing at you
and she it sounded so amazing i was like
i am in way over my head
i am doomed here and so anyway you're
like i'm gonna marry her that's how
he was so right he was so right we got
uh we got married and we instantly
started writing she was a
singer-songwriter and i was always in
collaborations and
bands and she was like a wordsmith and
so
she instantly like turned my brain on to
like that potential music because i was
one of like those typical dudes that was
interested in melody and music but i was
just like lyrics were just
in the background of the song for me and
she like really gave me a love for that
so that's
that's how our like really our band got
started in our marriage and our kids and
so it's kind of everything
that's very fascinating yeah that's
weird one of the things that
that bring us here is because your last
album
uh is kind of causing a stir in the
symbolic world
world you would say because
that you wrote it what in 2018 or you
came out and
when did you write you write it okay so
i guess there's other background
required is that all of our albums all
of our you know the last 10 years
have been concept albums where i'll
write a story
and then i will record i'll write down
the bullet points of that story in the
most important moments and then i'll
write songs for those
so it's a really um i really think art
flourishes when i have structure for me
like when i know and i have an
assignment and a boundary to play within
i will write within those boundaries so
i write the story
and then we fill in the blanks with the
song so we were wrapping up a record
called the raven locks
in 2017-2018 uh which was you know one
of the things about movies and music a
lot of times it's written
long before you ever record it so the
raven locks was wrapping up and i
needed a new story so 2018 rolled around
and this was a weird way like to come up
with an idea for record
so you're familiar with airbnb where you
rent houses you know
and travel so we had rented a house on
the gulf coast of florida to go on a
vacation
but right when we were about to leave
for the vacation like a red tide
had taken over and they weren't letting
people in the beach where the house was
and you know they were evacuating there
were dead fish everywhere it was
horrible and so
i was like of course this you know i'm
not going to be renting this house so
it sounded like a nightmare so you know
i messaged the guy i was like of course
you know we're gonna need to get out
this he's like oh that's fine you know
you can
but he's not gonna give us our money
back and i was like oh gee that's an
interesting turn of events so i looked
into the airbnb's
policy on like why you could cancel and
so i'm as i'm scanning through one of
the things was a pandemic
and i was like i hadn't really thought
about a pandemic our previous story
because we write light-hearted stuff had
to do with cholera a little bit so i
knew a little bit about how these things
function
but as i was starting to read about what
made something qualify as a pandemic
it the story like hit me and i was like
oh my gosh
like do you really like there's a i've
had this concern that our society
we're already like the social fabric is
disintegrating and people are already
pushing for a part
and if there was just some kind of like
even mild uh pandemic like
what would be the implications of that
so i just started writing a story
about that idea so
yeah 2020 rolled around and we had
released almost
we released our records and chunks
almost like a pulp thing um
where we were releasing an eps and
everything but the last ep had come out
but
it was weird because like there were
things that were happening directly in
the headlines that we were singing about
and you know it is what it is i didn't
you know wasn't trying to predict a
pandemic
i was just paying attention to the world
and like i generally
write and deal with subjects that are
troubling me because
i don't i think i make music and i've
never been able to stop myself making
music because it's how i stay sane so i
like i
i use art to kind of like ground me and
explore the story because it's
easier for me to see how something fits
together when it all comes together as a
concept within
art and music than it is to just
abstractly just imagine what the world's
actually working like
so that was where dead horse came from
so in dead horse you have this story
it's all but there's also not just a
pandemic there's this whole idea of
kind of the edge of the world how all of
this is
is is related to
to and there's not just the pandemic but
also the reaction to the pandemic
and this idea of a world that is kind of
shut down and
and how this like kind of this prison of
i don't know how can i say this like
this prison that makes you safe but then
also
also takes everything away from you at
the same time
yeah so yeah so what i did is i riffed
on the idea of quarantine or a society
that was riddled with
series of quarantines for multiple
reasons um from even reasons of
personality where ideologies were too
different and people couldn't hear
couldn't hear things they didn't like
anymore they were too fragile and also
the idea that people just saw
everybody became a germaphobe and was
afraid of what everybody else presented
to them and the danger that presented
and also how companies would benefit
from that and how all the new technology
would benefit from that so the story
actually
is this weird kind of like i would say
like a rip van winkle structure where um
the characters find the means
to try to go into the future to escape
what's happening
um so it starts out in dead horse alaska
which is the namesake of the record and
dead horse alaska is in
prudent bay in the north edge of the
world and
that's where the alaskan pipeline begins
so the story starts when the alaskan
pipeline is turned on and it's this
power
and i you know i uh mythologized it so
they i i
talk about that within the story as if
they found like under some beast at the
bottom of the ocean and what were the
implications of that thing and what were
the desires of that beast
so um as we moved into dead horse you
know they go into the future and
when they wake up a hundred years later
i'm skipping really quickly just to get
to the point of
um what you've asked and that is that
they wake up into a world that's
the world we live in now but it's
accelerated so this pattern of spreading
out and everything's on the grid and
everything's distanced
and people are you know well sadly like
they are now we're communicating each
other through a little window like
before we started i picked like the best
angle in here
and i put like my favorite gear in the
shot and so like gearheads would see it
and like you know all like i'm kind of
breaking the wall but
this isn't what my life looks like i
mean there's other angles of this
trailer where i've pushed all the junk
that i was working on yeah yeah it's
like it was kind of a riff on some of
these ideas and what that would do to
uh personalities and people and also how
technology would try to solve that yeah
yeah yeah
um so maybe we can look at some of the
songs because one of the things that i
want to kind of
bring about uh is this idea of
pattern or pattern intuition and so you
know
in 2019 i said i i told people like get
ready for 2020 because it goes to me
crazy and then some people later said oh
jonathan predicted the future i'm like
i didn't predict the future it's like
it's it you know if you see a vase
tipping on the side of a table
and you then you tell people to watch
out because it's falling it's different
and i think that i mean obviously that's
a simplified version but i think
there are some people that have an
intuition about patterns and so
as you kind of look at the pattern then
you talk about them um
even without knowing it you you can end
up doing something like predict the
future
without trying to do that explicitly
it's just this attention
attention to the world attention to
patterns and then
and then kind of telling a story that
ends up formulating
this the to say that uh what's going on
even if it's implicit and it's not
completely
logical and understood yet yeah i mean i
guess before we dig into the story a
little more
that's really worth mentioning so when
we first got a record deal
we were making music independently i was
just making stuff on a computer at home
and it just started selling and i just
quit my job and i was like oh my gosh
this is
this is going really well and we did the
next thing you do is we try to find a
record label we had interest
and the problem with the record label
was that they they need to make money
and so what we were doing isn't like the
most obvious way to make money
um so there was this like oh they look
at they see talent or they see
you know like um they see something
that's marketable and then they try to
package it within
some kind of popular form so there was
this real push towards pop and so
my problem i always had when i was
interacting with pop is i think i made
my worst stuff because
there's this tendency just to copy what
everybody else is doing like you know
it's good when it fits the pattern but
you don't understand the pattern
necessarily
so simultaneously there was this other
thing happening where
um it was kind of where i started seeing
the world symbolically and i didn't know
it was a
good way to see the world or the right
way to see the world i just knew there
was power in it when it came to writing
so
like what we talked about you know with
this oil and i personified
the you know energy in the story or you
could take cancer culture and you could
give it some kind of monstrous
description and describe
you know come come up with some
analogous ways that that monster might
do the same thing
i realized there was so much it was so
much more impactful
when i would take the patterns i was
seeing and i would give them a will and
an intelligence
um and so that changed things and also
the other side of the change things is
where we realized where we were going to
be positioned as artists is that
it was also it takes place within a
world that has a beginning middle and an
end
and we as we're writing we found it was
a way
better sweet spot for us to imagine that
this was the end
um like it was that things were coming
to a close and the pattern was
about you know something new was ahead
so when once i started looking at this
world in these in
in these symbolic patterns and like
really
starting to see monsters in like demons
and things whether they were there or
not i didn't know
it just it suddenly it was like i had no
end to the ideas anymore it wasn't like
i was trying to find an idea for a pop
song it was like i have more ideas right
now than i know what to write about
it was changing the way i was looking
out out of the window
simultaneously i was obsessed with
genesis and the other
part i felt was missing from the world
was losing sight of what
human nature was and why it was there
and i got obsessed with the story of the
garden of eden
because it was such an incredible
description of like these
these weird desires for perfection or to
be divine or to be royal that we have
and that things shouldn't go wrong
and it just it started to explain
that in the story so i always keep that
story in mind
when it comes to like how consciousness
developed and that interpretation of it
is i throw that over everything whether
people like it or not like it's
that yeah but it doesn't necessarily
because you you've
internalized it it doesn't necessarily
appear that way this is one of the
things too that
even in the discussion with my brother
matters sometimes uh
sometimes we would say some we would
think like oh that's too obvious like
it's too obvious if we say something
this way or if we say it this way it's
too obvious
then you realize no it's not it's
actually it's actually not you see the
connection like
if you're using analogies you think that
it's the same as something else but
but people don't necessarily notice it
and so if you if you take the story of
the garden and you superimpose it over
another event yeah most people won't see
that it's the story of the garden like
they'll just see that it has
this amazing coherence to it or this
strange
intuitive coherence to it yeah and
people are so i think they're just we're
sitting on top of so many things we
didn't invent we're sitting on top of so
many things we used to have to do
ourself
we're so detached from how we get our
food and how even the
the car we drive is operates or how it's
built we can't repair it
i can't fix the computer i'm using we're
sitting on top of all this stuff that
just
um we we don't we start to reason
as if that's the actual starting point
for reality
and we all kinds of errors are being
made everywhere where
uh even especially in the political
spheres when you listen to the different
ends of the political narrative it's
like it's
totally detached from the the
substructure of what it what being is
itself what it means to be a
person in this world it's just it seems
so inorganic now it's starting to
it causes like a little bit of panic in
me when i realize like
how people see themselves and what they
think we are sometimes and so
really the the record at the end of the
day is a discussion
of like your nature and what you're
ignoring i didn't again that wasn't my
intention but when i look back at it
it's like trying to drive
the bottom of why you do what you do and
why you want what you want because we
don't question those things nearly
enough
all right so i want to look at some of
the songs right now because i think
because we've been talking about it
abstractly but people are gonna
are going to to see right away
especially people that have been
following this channel
are going to kind of see the patterns
pop out um
and so did you have a song you wanted us
to start with particularly
um okay so i well i guess this is worth
mentioning i
i hijacked um jonathan's uh symbolic
world intro with
uh a song and the song is called saints
one
so you've already heard the introduction
to that song and
uh i guess we could start there because
i think that's an interesting one
because right after i released that um
i just thought it was my idea for a
story but then like tim cook
you know from apple came out uh that's
his name right tim yeah tim cook yeah
yeah
he like literally just outlined the idea
like just straight i was like oh okay i
was it's a weird moment when you do this
because
like we let's just say you're gonna come
up with a prediction of the future and
it's not so bright
there's a weird moment of satisfaction
you have when you're like aha i was
right and then you're like
oh no i was right no it's like
here come the terminators i knew it i
knew it great
wonderful um all right and so let me
read some of the
some of the uh so tell me the concept of
the song first of all and then we can
look at some of the actual lyrics
okay the song is interesting because it
it
intentionally steals christian imagery
of
the saints and redemption and absolution
but it's being used in a pattern to
advertise
this technology that is supposed to
solve
your felt needs so so the the needs that
people are trying to solve now
um are generally this idea and like you
know tim cook says it in his speech that
like
like there's it's immoral to despair or
it's unethical to despair
and this is this way that technology
companies look at you or even anybody
selling a product to you
is this is here to make you feel better
about yourself
feel better about life um you know to
give to take you one farther step down
that red carpet towards your throne
and so what happens is is this this
abandoned structure in the world where
there's like people used to venerate
saints
and they decide to well they come up
with an acronym s-a-i-n-t-s
and it describes the technology and
acronyms are so wonderful like they're
so
acronyms are like one of the diseases of
the modern world are
yeah are these acronyms well and so part
you talk about this in your channel but
people can't help
so when a powerful thing gets abandoned
you know
people will pick it up and use it for
whatever they whatever they can they
won't understand the purpose of it so
they'll abuse it so in this song
it's basically this world where
everybody's detached and so fragile
and separated from connection they're
like well we're not going to get them
back together with people that doesn't
work so we're going to create this
ai this embodied technology that's going
to go
and it's going to solve their felt needs
it's going to oprah winfrey their
self-esteem and uh and so that's what
the saint
saints is and so this song is like
they're opening ceremonies for the
revealing of this technology
um so that's it's it's their propaganda
is how i would see it in the story right
exactly all right so here we
[Music]
you go up with an ache
for something to set you apart
strip the scales from your heart
a hostage tied up by its nature
that can't happen sheathing its claws
[Music]
redemption has come
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
numbers
[Music]
[Applause]
so i mean it's pretty wonderful to see
like there's
the imagery is is really powerful first
of all this idea of
uh this idea of you want to be special
you want to be set you apart and it's a
great it's a great
way of saying it because it actually
that's what being holy is right
when you say something is holy we say
it's set apart and so you have this
desire to be holy
and to strip the scale from your heart
to remove those outer garments you know
and
get to the to the middle but then then
you realize that it's this factitious
factitious thing that they're presenting
and it's also this idea i love how it's
like
i want to all of a sudden this idea of
when the saints go marching in and says
i want to be in their number and then it
talks about the light begins to shine
all of a sudden
you realize this weird kind of uh 666
image right of this
of this total system that will identify
you that will name you that will shine
its light on you
you know and make it impossible for you
to to hide like you said to hide
in any form of negativity it's like
we're going to make you
happy by whatever it means necessary
right and the ned flanders that that
simpsons episode
with uh ned flanders like there's this
simpson episode like halloween episode
where ned flanders takes over the
the world and he has re-education
seminars where
everybody has to say that everything's
okay and they they force them into
smiles like
they pull hooks their their their lips
up into smiles
that's exactly it that's exactly it well
because i mean the
the reality is that these narratives are
detached from how things really work
and so the everything every
person who doesn't fit the narrative is
is evidence against it
so that's why you have to force
conformity because the reality won't
conform to this idea so you have to
use muscle it's like the you know
there's an autopilot's heading in a
different
way and you you don't want to go there
and so you have to muscle up and see how
long you can hold the wheel going in a
different direction and so that's
what happens in these this totalizing
system is that it just
it doesn't work people break from the
inside out even if they you know can't
get at each other
yeah exactly and it's you can see it now
because it's creating
it's creating these weird side effects
that they they
i guess they probably haven't planned
for and now they're constantly trying to
to patch over and to compensate and you
know to actually
at this while they want to kind of
include everybody to make everybody part
of this total system
then they nonetheless end up having this
strange desire to
totally exclude those that don't want to
be in the system
you know that's the problem right that
is that that's the problem with this
kind of system is that
because it presents itself as this
totalizing system
then those who don't want to be in the
system are
they're not human or they're barely
human they're you know they're
they they don't have a place well you
can't have equity if you're around other
people either
like so the problem is the more things
you equalize the more the things that
can never be equalized
um exaggerate it's just it's just what
happens i mean like one of the jokes i
make with people is like
a world that's trying to let's just say
men and women are all the same
is a world that also suddenly it's like
cool to have a beard
and it's like well why did that happen
you know should we all be clean-shaven
um but also there's um yeah there's this
well the notion is so like
just thinking down this idea is that if
you don't deal with the problems in
there in
the traditional places we dealt with
problems now you have to so you don't
know where the problem lies
and so everybody's a problem so yeah so
you have to treat everybody
as an equal offender of being diseased
as
a being a uh potential a potential
insurrectionist you want to say it that
way like that everybody's a problem so
everybody has to get away from each
other
and uh that's the problem with that that
system is the end result is if you
really try to stick to it eventually you
have to isolate everyone from each other
to
actually have equal because otherwise
you're going to just observe
inequalities that exist through any
difference
anytime your insight on that is so good
because
it's it's almost happening kind of on
its own in the sense that
i don't i can't imagine that that some
people maybe
like there are people that evil that are
sitting around and thinking
we need to isolate everybody from each
other as much as possible
for our system to function it almost
happens organically
out of the necessities of their desires
which
is like they because they want this
this thing this kind of they want
everybody to be included
the only way they can do it like you
said is to actually limit real
interactions between people
because in those real interactions
hierarchies will appear
inevitably like you can't avoid it so
now there's still one of the things they
realize with the technology
that there is too much individual
variation in between people
so they they do almost like what you do
when you try to hack a pop song
is where you try to find this the
commonalities and like you try to come
up with something universal i think a
really funny version of that is on the
show lost
is there this band called drive shaft
and their one hit song was called
you all everybody and it's like the most
generic like you who does that not
include you all everybody
and i just thought that was a really
perfect you know idea of like when you
try to hit the lowest common denominator
so
they can't properly produce an
intelligence that is reactive enough to
everybody
with their traditional means so they
outsource this idea to the collective
knowledge
and like the you know a samara uh summer
a summarizing look at all of the books
that have been produced and the songs
and
so the computer just collects everything
and
tries to understand it that way so it
just looks at what everybody how
everybody's already defined
things and then uses those definitions
and adapts
so um in the story there is a group
that's kind of like a knights templar
group that you know that protects the
holy grail and indiana jones
would be the way most people know about
that idea but there's this group that
sort of hates this technology and
they're they're they're sort of like
vanguarding this and so they decide to
take it down or they try to take it down
or break it
by using ambiguity that's naturally in
language so they they find the ideal
word
to mess with to break the technology and
that word is heart
because the heart is um well it's the
center it's
an actual organ in your body and it's
almost the same way in every language
every language uses this the same way
and uh but it has to do with affections
it has to do with things
and so they realize the best way to
break the system
and break the program is to mess with
the idea of the heart
and so that then you know all hell
breaks loose in my story once this
once this bug is introduced hmm all
right so
second song we wanted to look at it's
called it tore your heart out
and here you really get this you really
get this vision
which is which is powerful so i'll read
a little bit of it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from
[Music]
is
why
all right well gee this one was this one
was freaky because i had recorded it
and i hadn't i was just about to release
it
and it was i think was like march 13th
or march 15th and then it was
like oh we're all locked down in our
homes
and i was like oh gee this is a problem
and i
so i was looking at it and i was like oh
man well at least i had my head on
straight is what i thought and
i felt like i had some kind of well way
to look at what was happening
outside of just you know i did i never
believed
you know 15 days to flatten the curve i
just it never
never even occurred to me that that was
what was going to happen yeah you're
like this there's no way
there was just no way it was like
because like like you were saying
i don't you don't have to be a
conspiracy theorist to realize
where the opportunity lies in any given
situation like it
you don't need a group of people
planning behind closed doors to
plot against you because people are just
going to go where the money is and so
money is going to go to
the world that can a world that's
isolated so you know zoom
went through the roof and uh you know
amazon of course all these companies
really benefit from this and there's
incentive
for them to just keep making it easier
and easier for us to live like this so
i did i wasn't fooled by that for a
second but you know
if i was going to break that down a
little bit what's interesting to me is i
use this imagery as
they're locked alone in their lavish
homes with pets and wigs and their
bloated thrones
so that's the idea such a great image
well
there's so much there's so much to
dissect in that in that sentence
well everybody's gonna become a fop you
know it's like
if you don't know what a fop is just you
know go back and look at the you know uh
the signing of the declaration of
independence and wonder why these grown
men were wearing white wigs
and you know or watch mozart and you can
find out about that turkish
fashion movement but so i mean with your
filters and all the things people use
it's like yeah i have this really
controlled view and like oh man like
this guy's life is created studio is
awesome except for the mess over there
and uh so that was the thing is like i
just envisioned like
if you keep people in a place where the
only time they see other people is
through a little lens
it's they're they're going to spend all
of their resources
and time into that window yeah um and so
you know i just thinking about that and
i realized other things about it once i
started living in that world
it's like you know i'm in public and the
only time i'm in public no one
my identity is veiled so when i'm
actually with a person my identity is
failed but then when i'm with you
um it's not only am i not i'm it's my
full identity it's a hyper identity
because i'm looking in a mirror
you know i put it over here so i'd have
to do this to look at myself
but you're looking in a mirror yeah
while you're talking to someone else
everyone yourself like no the proper
psychological studies have not been
done on what the impact of that would be
yeah
talking to someone but seeing yourself
at the same time man it's a horrible
horrible idea it's like
there should be a fairy tale about it
but there's something about
this this paragraph which it's just so
powerful in the sense that
so the name of the song is it tore your
heart out and that's the the chorus
and so if you tear someone's heart out
if you tear
the heart out of something that is the
center if you tear the middle out of
this
out of it then what you're describing is
is such a powerful kind of modern
version of what that would look like
first of all this idea of the the the
suburban
uh hell for the living dead so the
suburbs are
are not the city they're this ambiguous
like margin of the city where everything
becomes
this like you know i've talked about
this before right everything gets spread
out and there's no center
there's no reason besides just kind of
being this these these independent
points on a map basically on the grid uh
this like spread over a piece of toast
kind of
and so that is that is a form of living
death because
you're there but you can't see the
reason there you can't understand why
you live
next to these people right there's
nothing bringing you together besides
just the factuality of just being in a
line of people on a street
you know and then this so then being
alone obviously
but also being uh the idea of pets and
wigs it's such a great image because it
has to do with the hair right it has to
do with
the extremities and these dead things
because this animal this animal part of
us like
it's also talking about kind of being
stuck alone with your desires in the
sense that it's like you're there and
you you
you don't have communion so you end up
also going into
uh you're you're in the danger of
falling into idiosyncrasy
right right and that's what the flop-ish
aspect of it too is like
going into these weird idiosyncratic uh
aspects of what it means to be
to be human and then coming coming
coming to it then to say
pure devotion to your skin which what
ends up being what this is all about
like this
this outer is this being stuck in this
outer
periphery alone in this uh in the in the
in the
in the periphery in the uh the edge of
the wheel let's say you're stuck on the
edge of the wheel
and then you then you compare it to the
opposite which is you flee communion
right which is where you find the heart
and then the cup is void and
it's just a perfect such a perfect thing
it's crazy like i said that you wrote
that
i mean i guess you could intuit that
like even if there wasn't like a plague
that happened that this was already
going on it was already going on yeah
that's
it i'm like dealing head on with
something i just it's just
where things were going that's that's
the trajectory of things it's like what
you're doing is that same thing you do
on the sats and they're like
they give you seven numbers and the next
three are blank and you have to
figure out the pattern right and
obviously there's more factors in life
than just
this number sequence but it's the same
thing it's like yeah like this is where
we're going this is what all the
technology is allowing us to do
people are tough people are a problem as
long as people define
their life as going wrong anytime they
have any kind of struggle
or that like you know god's favor has
left them if anything's difficult
you're that's the man i can sell that
person anything
right so that's part of the problem with
this is that the idea would it tore your
heart out
um you know because you didn't
understand why you want what you wanted
yeah you know so i met someone uh the
other day well someone actually knew
before this but
they had lost their sense of smell and
taste from this
you know this covered flu thing going
around so they um
they were like they're in perfect shape
it was so so silly they said this
they're like you would think i would
lose more weight
since i can't taste my food and i was
like no
you have to swallow your food like it's
weird like nobody thinks about this
anymore
like swallowing is the is more important
than the foods
taste at the end of the day because go
to your favorite restaurant like just if
they ever let you do this but
you'll never do it but go eat order your
favorite thing and chew it up and spit
it in a bucket and tell me how good of a
time you had yeah so
there are things in life that are fat
that take longer to develop than meals
that where if you didn't swallow your
food at the end like
there might be you know one of the
things i might realize about myself is
one day i might look back and like i
didn't have grandkids and i might feel
like i didn't swallow life like
that might hit me different you know as
i as i'm older
and so now i have kids but um there's
also other weird things like you know
you when you get hurt
like people don't understand like even
what's going on inside of them because
they think
it's all made up but you know if you
stub your toe on an object
you you have a weird thing to do where
instantly you you assign a will to that
object that hit you it's like it did it
on purpose you want to kick it back
yeah yeah you have to stop yourself from
destroying yourself because that's that
weird vengeance narrative we have that
only destroys us
but also at the same time you people
don't recognize when they're hurt
they feel isolated they like you boom
you zoom out from the rest of the world
and you're alone and they don't
understand suffering and loneliness go
hand in hand
so they there's this lack of
understanding of what's really going on
in our nature and we we don't question
enough i think that garden of eden story
is so great because you know i read uh
hymns in paradise and when i read him
the paradise
um you know i think i told you this and
i ended up writing a song on this record
about it
it was this idea that was like oh it was
like i remembered something i was trying
to remember my whole life
like or you know reminded me of
something i was trying to remember and
there is this sense of like we're
you know we have this evolution story
going around and i'm not
anti-evolution at all but i i don't
think the story says enough
because there are all kinds of desires
we have for paradise and for perfection
and for completeness and for things to
never go wrong that just don't make any
sense
where these squishy animals running
around and then i read the story and
suddenly it's like yeah we're like
like like mom died in the beginning of
the disney princess story and we're
trying to solve that problem
and so people don't know why they want
what they want and if they really
believe
that you know anytime something isn't
going their way
that that's wrong right that i
again you could sell them anything so
then bring it to the next song that i
wanted to look at
uh it's called but never a key and then
this song
really looks at the problem or let's say
the problem that the opportunity of
safety
gives and like this the the problem that
we have right now which is to see safety
as the ultimate value and to see this
this kind of safety and pleasure too
like this kind of idea that if you're
safe you can
can have your little pleasures and and
and i hear even the politicians talk
about that it's
drives me insane like here in quebec you
know they're like well
it'll be okay you know you can just you
can have naps and you can
watch tv and you can play video games
and it's like you know you can get the
rest that you've always wanted right
you've always wanted this so it's like
you can you can get that nice little
pleasant uh life that you that you wish
for uh so let me read a little bit from
this
[Music]
your tragedy
and i'm sure that they won't be done
till they fenced off the ledges and
rounded
the edges of all that goes wrong
[Music]
your maze is
i'm sorry you'll never be
free if all that you see
[Music]
is
[Music]
that you chose
all
but never a case
[Music]
never
yeah it's awesome there it is
yeah it's such a it's such an amazing i
mean it's really amazing to see that you
wrote this
you know several years ago yeah i mean
people came out in 2019
yeah so i mean and but it's also not
that long ago that it was
right on the edge of the pattern like it
was riding the edge of the pattern so
that when
things started to happen it was like it
was that thing
in that thing ahead of you that was
telling you to watch out that you didn't
listen to you know when you should have
yeah no i cried when i wrote that too
it's so sappy but like i
this thing hits me every once in a while
where like you condense something
into what feels like the right idea and
it's it's like
you know i think something's profound
when it's like you saw it but you didn't
have the words for it and then someone
comes up and they
say it in like a real concise way and
you're like the light bulb goes off but
not because you weren't already seeing
it you were seeing it so like
when i wrote this it just hit me i was
like because i mean this obviously this
all these ideas are present beforehand
because
um you know again like this like
everybody is just so concerned about
it being in a pleasured state and
there's so many things on tap
that can like you can just satiate so
many different things without any
hesitation
um and so when i wrote this song it's
like
yeah i mean this is this is what's
happening people are going to people are
going to accept a cage
that's what's that's where we're head if
something doesn't happen it's different
this is what's going to happen yeah i
mean it's already there it's there right
now i would say
it's just like it's like maybe we have
the sense that it's going to stop but
it could get worse it could get a lot
worse it could get a lot worse
so daniel keys wrote this song this
story called flowers for algernon and
he wrote the story based upon experience
he had with a real life
student who had a brain injury who he
was teaching to read again and then they
went away for summer break and the
student came back and the student had
forgotten
everything and he was devastated he went
and wrote this the story flowers for
algernon
if you haven't read it uh i would check
it out really great book
um it's funny that it's called but never
a key and his last name is keys
but um so one of the things they tried
to do when he went to publish it is
everybody was like oh what a great story
what a cool sci-fi story
um yeah just make the ending happy and
we'll run with this
and he refused and finally someone
published it and it was like a pulitzer
prize winner and then
they wanted to make it into a film in
hollywood i think the film's called
charlie
and uh they're like yeah we're just
gonna make it have a happy ending and
he's like no
it's not real if it has a happy ending
so he
wouldn't sell it until they made it his
way and uh
so the whole idea here is that saying
this this idea of the devouring mother
that
you know like okay kids had seven
cupcakes but like here comes the eighth
and he wants it and you can't say no
because you think your job is to keep
everybody
like you sinned against someone if they
are upset with you um
so that's the whole idea is like we're
gonna you know you just look at the if
you're old enough
like uh so you can see that there used
to be not not used to be rails on
certain things and
they didn't force you to wear seat belts
and some of this is good
but also like everything's getting
padded out there yeah yeah yeah
i love it so they fenced off the ledges
and rounded the hedges
yeah yeah right
so that's it's just what's happening
it's like that's you know
that's too if you're in like politics
you've got to look for the sharp pointy
objects sitting out there that are still
left so you have a purpose
yeah right and there's something from
somebody something like you said it's
already there so like i i think i might
have told the story
on the channel before but i one of the
things that when i was when my kids were
younger and we go to the park
there's this one moment that hit me like
it just hit me so hard
i saw there were these children and this
child
was playing in the park the child starts
running and then the mother says or
who's the father i don't remember if it
was a man or woman says
don't run you'll fall in a park
no i was like what did you just tell
your child not to run because they will
fall that is the most insane thing i've
ever heard
yeah oh like it's grass it's like that's
fine to fall on grass that's where you
do fall
yeah exactly right they better learn to
fall there um all right so last song i
wanted to look at
all right obviously it's a perfect song
to also to finish off our
analysis uh it's called no land beyond
and here's part of it
[Music]
[Applause]
if you don't know of the language
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
when the world is upside down follow the
fool for solid ground
that's awesome it's a very pejoring line
very in line but it's
but it's great because it also talks
about this idea that
that this problem of not knowing the
language or the language falling apart
like to say the sacred language falling
apart
and then people not being able to
recognize the patterns and then at that
moment
you know it it creates this madness
because people don't know what's going
on they
they can't recognize you know the
world's falling apart but they don't
understand why they can't see it if they
could only
they only knew the language then they
would notice that this is part of the
story
and this is where we are it would give
them some some
some strange comfort to be able to at
least realize what's going on to to
to to limit this side effects or limit
the adverse effects of
being in this pattern um and then of
course you know
at that moment like you said there's
only one last the
last thing left to do so one of the
thing is it's like so
what i saw this part of the song as i
did it as a canon because these are like
things i think that are swirling around
right now
like these these are problems that are
swirling around right now and every once
in a while there's this like
there's this one little light that pops
up and there's so many stories that just
seem so politically driven
and and the world is filled with so much
mush that
it's like people don't understand the
structure of reality or how to see it
because it's
again we're sitting on top of something
so inorganic and uh
so but the the fool in there is like the
is this idea i tell a story it's like if
you're ever like stuck and you've run
out of ideas and
and you need to make a decision and
nobody has an idea
you look for the most foolish person in
the group and you get them drunk and you
listen to them
it's it's this idea like when like you
know because
everything's so everything's so
counterintuitive
that it's like oh the person who's is
the anomaly who's saying the
thing that doesn't fit the system might
actually have the answer for this broken
system
so that's part of the to the and the end
we're all mad men
is that um one of the ways i see life is
like
you know this is another type of womb
like we had a we were a child we were in
a womb
and there are parts of us we don't need
yet
that are there you know so it might be i
don't remember being a baby to you but
um
there might be parts where it was
awkward to have legs and arms like but
that you need in life
and and there's this moment where right
before you're born where
it's the least hospitable space you're
just you're you're scrunched in there
and
life kind of works like that too in the
sense that are still there are still
things
that are in us um that we don't know
what they're there for and we don't know
why these desires are here
and there's they're on the other side of
a thing we can't see yet
but so part of where i was like
realizing like the power
was in us writing about the end of the
world all the time
was that that's what life feels like
we're crunched up against the edge of
this thing
we're just we're and that
things make less and less sense our
bodies are changed by this technology we
don't understand how this technology has
really
shaped our body away even to want things
that aren't
a part of our nature so uh i think that
that's the in the end we're all mad men
is that there's
that moment of birth that's ahead like
you want to look at it that way it's
like just doesn't make it's not good for
anybody in that moment
it's not good for the mom it's not good
for the baby like but it needs to happen
and we seem to be at this point where
everything's just getting crushed yeah
you know in
in the next things just around the
corner so uh
that's and then our life also like i
mean when you talk about looking at
patterns our life is just
you know our every day is a really good
example of what your life is like and
the way you wake up you get to your feet
you become aware you get energy you run
out of energy you get sleepy and you lay
down
that's a life in general too and so the
world just seems to be
like right there it's like run out of
stuff and it's everybody's getting lazy
and weird
and and stressed and crunched and
meanwhile we can satiate
all of our desires and so it's just the
madness is abounding
yeah exactly yeah like you said it is
it's like it's the end of the day
and that's the moment where people don't
know what to do
and so some people will play games some
people
will get sleepy some people will try to
satiate themselves
just put the tv on until they fall
asleep exactly
that definitely it definitely feels like
where we are and so
but i i think that i i really appreciate
you kind of
positing it as this hope you know as
this capacity through the pattern to be
able to see beyond this
this first veil that appears to us
because sometimes i get lost and
i get discouraged because you know i all
i see
is the breakdown and i don't realize
like you said
in an absolute truth which if there's a
breakdown it means that there's
a resurrection on the other side and so
if we can keep our
focus on on that then then all of this
madness will won't be as difficult to
bear
yeah too for artists and just the
average person too i mean it's like
there's no less good in the world
it's just in fewer and fewer places um
which means that when you see it
hopefully it shines brighter so like
that's the hope at the end of the tunnel
is that as
people like kind of give in to this
hedonism and
you know this this self-indulgence is
that it just makes
what's good left shine brighter so it
stands out
yeah yeah all right neil this is awesome
i really appreciated it and
and so i would say everybody check out
dirtport robbins
we'll put all the links i hope you
appreciated this
i am really uh i'm excited for the
things that are coming down the line we
have some
some announcement to make very soon uh
about some
some uh stuff that neil and i and other
people that you know are working on so
we're excited to announce that very soon
so stay tuned to that and uh neil i wish
you the best
thank you it's good to talk to you